all right elmer
elmer uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally a chair in eastern
kentucky
this is leslie county leicester county
yeah tell me about your childhood you
had
both your parents when you were yeah
yeah how was your childhood
never mind it was nine of you yeah
i'm the baby in the family
you're the youngest youngest one yeah
how would you describe your childhood
it growled up pretty rough right there
just hard living
raised on cornbread and soup beans
taters
garden grown a big garden every year
hogs you guys have electricity and
running water
no no we're not for a long time
yeah how far did you go in school i went
through the
9th grade that's great yeah
did you do for work after you finished
school well i've worked uh drove a trip
about all my life
hauled coal logs
and been into logging last
10 15 years yeah appalachia
it's a tough region to survive in right
real
work and finding work it's a hard thing
now
yeah coal mines and stuff didn't work
you
my grandma always said she said if
you're gonna
eat suffer with me you gotta work you
won't feed nobody don't work
but uh so you've had uh
you've been married have kids yeah yeah
i've got two little boy and a girl
and you raised them yeah yeah my wife
she passed on
i'm sorry so your kids stayed here and
uh
yes for a raise the mountains so
yeah why do people choose to stay here
even though there's very few
opportunities and
such a tough life this mountain gets to
you after a while you just
don't feel at home nowhere else you go
somewhere else and it just doesn't feel
right
yeah yeah there's something about this
region that's very special
home you know yeah
drugs have kind of taken over this
region oh pretty much took over yeah
why do you think that's happened
bothered me
why do you think that's happened i don't
know
i don't know it's it's bad though sure
yeah bad bad situation you've got
involved in that as well
have you got involved in drugs at all no
never no good for you
what do you think the future is of this
region because uh
you know technology marches on in the
rest of the country but this
part of the country is kind of being
left behind yeah
i live on you can't just garbage people
left they know how to raise gardens
heal hogs uh eat squirrels
what do you live on now i mean what's
your income i just
disability disability yeah how much do
you live on
a year ah i get so much month
what do you get a month roughly about
1100 a month
i'm a total disability that's enough to
live on yeah
well i might do it what garden to grow
stuff i put away do a lot of canning
count a lot of food yeah but are you
happy here yeah
yeah ain't no place like home yeah and
you're not looking to live
no no yeah i like to go on vacation
sometimes
in florida how far have you traveled i
used to go to florida sometimes about
once a year take a vacation and
sometimes myrtle beach yeah since this
coco night team come out i ain't went
nowhere i stayed pretty much at the
house yeah
do you have any regrets in your life do
you look back and say you wish you'd
done this or wish you'd done that
no no yeah you're happy with that i'm
happy we
yeah what are the best and worst things
about living in appalachia
uh it's it's i guess
i don't know i don't say much bad things
myself i
i kind of look you know got a point of
view looking at the good side
i'm well happy here
you know it's real fleeting it's a very
simple life though yeah
you got to get real food yeah you raise
your own food
right right a lot of garden food yeah
hogs how old are you
chickens 55 55.
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
trusting god
you're a religious man no but i believe
in god
you don't go to church no i did but
i'm kind of backslid
so how do you spend your days typically
what do you what do you do buddy just
work around the house
pedal about you know do a lot of
yard work work here trying to get set up
my trailer set up and everything
right what do your kids do yeah my boy
is a
logger he logs and my daughter she
i think she works as a nursing home
and got good kids i ain't on drugs thank
god
that's correct you know that
methamphetamine took over this place
it has it's got it's ruined all the
young people
well not all of them but a lot of them
yeah but it was it was the
pain pills and then uh the mayor that
nice to me if they'll make it
it's it's about to do a mile wind yeah
well it almost seems like
almost the entire community is it's
it's bad it's true it's rare to find
somebody who isn't
what opportunities are there for a
person staying choosing to stay here
coal ministers log woods or
like walmart or somewhere like that
working they ain't
ain't but if you get education you have
to leave them here yeah
you know yeah and you get a real job you
have to leave here right
but you feel like you you've lived the
life you wanted
i yeah i'd like to go with the lord a
lot sooner you know
it's pretty wild my childhood days yeah
what kind of stuff did you get into
i smoked pot and drunk a lot yeah
the drink and i quit i still smoke a
little pot alone i consider it as herb
not not a drug right it's
it's illegal here oh yeah yeah yeah they
ain't legalized
like they have uh california like right
yeah for us it's like
they don't take it so seriously yeah
it's a good it's a good pine mess
but you live in this trailer behind you
yeah you have electricity now
yeah you have running water yeah you do
yeah i run it off a holler up there i've
got a
waterfall that's where it comes off of
so you tap into that
yeah yeah you can't drink it but i'm
bathing it and
wash my clothes and dishes and your
friends
huh you have friends oh yeah yeah i got
friends
not many but a few you know you don't
need a lot
i still stay a lot to myself
by myself first i've got a wife but she
lives in
another home and i live here i
understand
and uh do you hunt yeah what kind of
animals do you hunt for
deer squirrel rabbit
snakes
get buried here yeah one comes in here
every night
really yeah got one coming out big bear
he's my bulldog two three times
he tore him up pretty bad last time he
cut him up
but now he'll he'll get after you
so living up here all by yourself elmer
is there anything that you do
to protect yourself well i've got a
pistol i packed with me
was that right yeah i keep it for the
bears
the bears bad to come in on me after the
night
how close how close the bears get to you
oh they've come stuck their heads
through the door at me
and they took them into your trailer
yeah i left the door open one night and
there's one come stuck its head so
the door looked at me and that's where
it comes in handy yeah i got a pistol i
had a rifle
and i keep it for snakes and
and people it's mean to me tries to be
mean to me i ain't able to fight them
i'd have to shoot them it's just you
know rough living here in the mountains
you gotta
gotta protect yourself snake is bad the
bears is bad
some big cats running around here
and some main people running around here
but i don't bother me
i guess where i gotta go and they ain't
no better
they don't mess with you no i don't mess
with me i don't mess with nobody neither
tell my grandpa he was a he was a doctor
a lawyer undertaker
and he'd take in sick people
and he'd taken a nurse from the health
and if they died
he would take and build a coffin and
preach the funeral and bury him
he did have some slaves back in his day
and time
yes yeah and my grandma right there she
raised kids after and stuff and and
she'd breastfeed them
and panthers would come and try to claw
in on her
they'd stick her piles through the door
she'd chop their piles off
of a hatchet and uh this is your
grandparents
yeah they was they they had it rough
back in
but the slaves they grow corn feed the
animals with they had mules
oxes my grandpa was a
rapid old dude buddy so he was a doctor
a large lawyer undertaker and a preacher
he done a little bit outlet and up there
where he lived his big log house
and he buried all of them out in the
bottom right there alvin people would
die he'd bury him they've graves that
ain't never been marked
i'd say 50 60 graves a pair it ain't
never been marked
but he's a go-getter that old man was
jake napper was his name
and uh he just
you know he's out there he put you when
i was a kid right there if you killed a
pissaint on his part he was whooped
he called them little people he didn't
believe in killing nothing unless he was
gonna eat it
and that pretty much covered that
all right elmer well thank you so much
for talking with me yes sir
good luck with everything and and the
bears too oh yeah
all right in all times of bears